- Morgen, Jungs. Alles klar? Super.
Dann müssen wir sehen,
dass wir relativ fix durchkommen,
dass wir schnell arbeiten.
Dann machen wir Folgendes:
Du machst deine Gemüseseite,
du machst gleich die Aufbauten.
Und du bist ja jetzt gerade mal den zweiten
Tag hier, du machst grad einfach Folgendes:
Du hilfst vorne bei Obst.
Dann legen wir los!
So, wir haben ja heute die
Aktion mit den Kirschen,
die sind diese Woche im
Sonderangebot für 7,29 Euro das Kilo.
Die kommen jetzt gerade
frisch vom Bauern.
Die müssen hier mit rein, weil
das farblich wunderbar passt.
Da guckst du aber trotzdem
mal eben vorher durch,
weil Kirschen sind sehr anfällig,
sie werden sehr schnell schlecht.
Kann natürlich sein, dass du die
eine oder andere Kirsche findest.
Du packst das dann hier vorne,
wo die freie Fläche ist.
Da musst du dann einfach
die Kirschen reinräumen.
- So!
Du guckst jetzt erst mal, dass
du hier die Kartons einräumst.
Das ist hier vorne das Regal, ne?
Eigentlich siehst du die ganzen Produkte.
Die findest du auf jeden Fall.
Kleiner Tipp:
Wenn du gleich hier die freie Fläche hast,
ne, schaust du gerade nur aufs Etikett.
Die letzten zwei Ziffern hier von
dieser langen Nummer,
die stehen immer auf dem
Produkt drauf hier, ne?
Die 62 passt hier mit dem Etikett.
- Okay. Weiß ich Bescheid.